[Music]
the whole message of all three
descendants movies is that it doesn't
matter where you come from which to me
is the ultimate empowerment is realizing
that you're the captain of your own ship
you're in charge of your own life DK's
were the Trailblazers it kind of
inspires a new generation of people who
look at us and go oh maybe we can also
follow in those footsteps become
something that we've maybe always wanted
to be but never had the chance to sort
of express that and all of us should do
our best to ensure that everyone has
that opportunity to dream to have hope
to aspire to travel I can't believe I
can't with you in your very own job you
tell a real tale at its fore people can
watch the movie and maybe without even
knowing it relate to the characters
we're talking about closing the barrier
for good but you said no choices are so
important making good choices and
unselfish choices choices that just
don't benefit you but benefit everyone
we are all capable of good and bad no
matter which side of the barrier we come
from it's my favorite part of what this
movie is about all of us are just really
honored to be a part of something so
global and so lovely and you have no
idea that it would turn into what it has
and I think will forever be grateful for
that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]